olaf scholz wird in dieser woche offen
gestalten als der bremser europas ex
nato chef rasmussen wirft ihm
zögerlichkeit vor verlangt wir brauchen
deutsche führung der ukrainische
aussenminister kollegah ist auf die
deutsche verteidigungsministerin
wirklich wütend heißt es und der
oppositionsführer im bundestag
kritisierte in berlin direkt interview
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat bis
zum heutigen tag keine schweren waffen
geliefert andere tun längst mehr ich
gehe so weit zu sagen wenn sich alle so
verhalten würden wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland dann hätte die russische
armee liegt bereits eingenommen und doch
die kritik tropft ab an scholz er äußert
sich viel in dieser woche aber sagt
wenig wo bleiben die versprochenen
schweren waffen da arbeiten wir jetzt
dran das wird relativ zügig ging es
zügig ja wenn wir die zusagen von
anderen haben außen sind dass der geräte
die hergerichtet werden müssen das weiß
auch hier wird die industrie die ersten
15 gepard panzer frühestens im juli in
die ukraine schicken können dabei hatte
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht
persönlich schwer in der kritik für ihre
amtsführung schon vor vier wochen
schnelligkeit versprochen alle
militärexperten sind sie sicher dass die
nächsten zwei wochen entscheidende
wochen sind deswegen geht es auch sehr
schnell das ist schnelle unterstützung
darum geht es und es jetzt wochen sodass
monate ich denke das kann recht zügig
geschehen zügig das ist fast vier wochen
her immer offensichtlicher die zwei
geschwindigkeiten innerhalb der ampel
die grünen so hört man haben den export
schwerer waffen schon vor wochen intern
bewilligt manche der damals schon sagte
das problem sitze im kanzleramt
beherrscht sich jetzt nur mühsam vor der
kamera es darf sich nicht weiter
verzögern was mit dem gepard panzern ist
dass es zwar auf der einen seite das
gerät gibt auch die munition schwierig
ist es muss jetzt beim ringtausch
nachgelegt werden da beschweren sich
osteuropäische partnerinnen also polen
beschwert sich slowakei ist auch nicht
ganz glücklich also mehr tempo und noch
einer liegt nach markus ferber als
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher der
fdp gestürzt weil er seinem unmut über
scholz laut luft gemacht hatte schreibt
wir tun nicht was wir können und weiter
von 380 x dann liefern wir 0 von 800
fixen liefern wir 0 von 300 leoparden
liefern wir null und jahr von 120
haubitzen liefern wir 7 warum also
bremst die spd ist es der kanzler selbst
der immer wieder vor einer eskalation
mit russland warnt oder wird er
ausgebremst von seiner
bundestagsfraktion mit dem pazifisten
mützenich an der spitze olaf scholz
reist viel heute zum beispiel nach
afrika aber weiterhin nicht nach kiew
und findet dafür immer wieder neue
gründe ich würde nicht mit einreihen in
eine gruppe von leuten die für ein
kurzes rein und raus und ein fototermin
was machen scholz düpiert damit alle die
schon da waren aussenministerin
bundestagspräsidentin
eu-kommissionspräsident in aber niemand
vermisst scholz in kiew behauptet die
spd auf europäischer ebene habe ich die
diskussion um reisen nach kiew noch nie
vernommen es ist ja auch so dass zum
beispiel im manual makro oder joe biden
noch nicht in kiew waren also das ist
schon eine sehr deutsche debatte ich
habe auch manchmal das gefühl eine sehr
parteipolitisch
geführte debatte aber sie schadet dem
kanzler er mache seine sache in der
ukraine krise gut sagen über scholz nur
noch 50 prozent der deutschen bei robert
habeck sind es 67 bei annalena baerbock
sogar 74 prozent
kommunikation ist ja nicht nur das
verlesen von erklärungen und das sind
eben sowohl habig als auch berbalk
einfach vielfältiger unterwegs und sie
produzieren auch die besseren bilder als
die manchmal als trüge wahrgenommene
präsentation des kanzlers parteichef
klingbeil muss ich das dieser tage immer
wieder anhören wie hier in einer online
debatte die grünen kommen einfach besser
rüber schreiben gleich mehrere user
scholz hat halt den eindruck vermittelt
er herum zu eiern ein anderer bei scholz
muss man erst mal alle schachtelsätze
analysieren der olaf scholz kennt der
weiß dass er niemand ist der
wasserstandsmeldung kommuniziert der
kommuniziert entscheidungen der sagt das
was auf den weg gebracht wurde und das
ist sein kommunikationsstil der im am
ende ja auch im recht gibt glaube ich an
vielen stellen ausgerechnet jetzt ein
kanzler der nur schwer verstanden wird
trifft auf schwache
verteidigungsministerin
für ein gespräch zum thema angefragt
haben wir die verteidigungsministerien
christine lambrecht die wehrbeauftragte
ev hügel den spd vorsitzenden lars
klingbeil den fraktionsvorsitzenden rolf
mützenich absagen von alt wer sich
stellt ist die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin im
verteidigungsministerium die vorher
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin der
spd war gut nach oldenburg sind immer
drin hand wir haben es ja eben gesehen
im beitrag der fdp
verteidigungspolitiker marcus faber
schreibt von 380 mörder liefern wir 0
von 800 fixen 0 von 300 leopard liefern
wir 0 immerhin sieben haubitzen kann die
bundesregierung nicht oder will sie
nicht
ich möchte dazu zwei dinge festhalten
erst mal haben wir gemeinsam im nato
bündnis mit allen westlichen nationen
festgehalten die entscheidung wird auch
gemeinschaftlich getragen dass keine
schützen oder kampfpanzer westlichen
modells geliefert werden und dazu gibt
es auch bisher keine veränderung der
position aller westlichen nationen und
dann ist die andere sache natürlich kann
man die bestände der bundeswehr schauen
und trotzdem muss man festhalten dass
wir die bestände der bundeswehr in die
nato-verteidigungsminister und
instrumente ein gemeldet haben und
darüber nicht nur unsere eigene
sicherheit gewährleisten so auch die des
gesamten bundesgebietes und dann
zugleich das natürlich von den zahlen
die da sind die ich auch in dieser
stelle nicht so explizit bestätigen
wollen würde aber dann den von der
anzahl von schweren waffen systemen
sogenannten schweren waffensystemen die
wir haben nicht alle jahr vollumfänglich
einsatzbereit sind weil sie sich
routinemäßig auch instandhaltung
befinden oder auch im übungs maßnahme
finden
naja also von diesen die instand gesetzt
werden müssen der chef von rheinmetall
hat beispielsweise anfang april schon
gesagt sie könnten die ersten zehn bis
20 mal binnen sechs wochen fertig machen
hätten sie es damals entschieden dann
könnte ja jetzt schon geliefert werden
es ist eine einheitliche position nicht
nur innerhalb der bundesregierung
sondern auch innerhalb der westlichen
nationen keine schützenpanzer oder
kampfpanzer westlichen modells zu
liefern und wenn wir wenn es eine
veränderung der position geben sollte
dann müsste das auch innerhalb des
nature nature and i councils und
zumindest ein bundessicherheitsrat
abgestimmt werden bis dahin
habe ich keine veränderung der position
auch zwischen den unterschiedlichen auch
mit den fdp- ressorts vernehmen können
und dementsprechend ist da die position
der bundesregierung eindeutig und
konzentriert aber man kann sich
natürlich auch vorbereitet für den fall
der entscheidung die forderung der
ukraine nach marder panzer die wurde ja
abgelehnt sagte die 343 die man habe
sein zitat unabkömmlich in einem jetzt
bekanntgewordenen internen papier heißt
es aber 62 davon würden nicht mehr
genutzt und rund die hälfte davon könnte
wieder instand gesetzt werden stimmt
denn das
ich würde mich auch da ungerne zu den
zahlen 1 1 lassen der die zahlen sind
geheimhaltungs würdig allerdings ist es
so dass natürlich altes material instand
gesetzt werden kann und da muss man über
den planungs und den den zweitore ist
antreten für diese bezifferten marder
schützenpanzer brauchen wir mindestens
bis nächstes jahr uns in stand zu setzen
und das hilft eher der ukraine im moment
auch nicht wir haben die anzahl von
einsatzbereiten schützenpanzern bei der
nato entweder in den zaun oder in der
btf eingemietet und sind dringend auf
sie angewiesen um die sicherheit für
deutschland und das nato-bündnis gebiet
gewährleisten zu können aber bleiben wir
noch aber den marathon warum hat man
dann nicht gleich im märz den auftrag
zur instandsetzung erteilt denn dann
könnten die margen noch in diesem jahr
zum einsatz kommen
ich kann es nur wiederholen es bisher
konzentrierte position der
bundesregierung als solche über den
bundessicherheitsrat abgestimmt das ist
keine veränderung der position gibt was
die baader aus dem bundeswehr beständen
an gibt und auch was die
ausfuhrgenehmigung grundsätzlich von
solchen waffensystemen anbetrifft und
das ist abgestimmt im bündnis der nato
und auch damit europäische position
natürlich könnte man das so tun
allerdings hat sich bisher aufgrund von
politischen und auch völkerrechtlichen
überlegungen die position innerhalb des
westlichen bündnisses nicht verändert
thomalla ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch einen schönen abend noch ich
danke ihnen